nationally a lot of frustration among
travelers this holiday weekend but so
far no major problems here in las vegas
we have team coverage for you this
afternoon mary jane belliesa gives a
peek at the status of holiday road trips
but first let's go out to madison
kimbrough at reed international airport
where people seem to be in good spirits
so far as their flights are on time for
now hi madison
yeah some positivity in the air this
fourth of july weekend as people head to
baggage claim here at terminal three and
although national flight delays are
causing real frustration here at harry
reid international it's been nothing but
a smooth landing so far according to
flight aware as of now more than 4
thousand flights have been canceled
nationally but here at harry reid
international we have seen just over 100
delays with just over 15 canceled
flights however airlines across the
country are struggling with pilot and
staffing shortages here in las vegas
travelers say they understand and add
that they're just happy to be here
traveling during the holiday weekend was
not a concern for me it was no delays i
mean it was pretty good a pretty good
experience left on time we went through
omaha and
got in with no problems
delta airlines is handing out travel
waivers to some passengers impacted by
operational delays that airline is also
said to be moving employees around to
compensate for staffing shortages
currently as you can see most flights
here have arrived on time we're looking
at the arrivals with airline spirit and
southwest seeming to have the most
delays at harry reid international thus
far reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now